Wren: It's discouraging.
Carmichael:
W: [clearing throat]
W:
W: So, now that we have all the cameras together, we can sync them up, but...
W: ...how do we do that?
W: I'm gonna start rolling.
W: And they are rolling now.
W: Sync it with my helmet.
W: [anticipatory breath]
SFX: Woody thunk, slice, splatter
SFX: Portal shot
W: I connected all of them to this remote here.
W: Somehow, for syncing it, you can do, like, a visual, like -
W: ...a clapperboard sorta style, but...
W: I don't know how you're supposed to clap for something that's looking everywhere.
W: So, my solution is, literally, to take this helmet,
W: ...drape it over,
W: ...hold it for, like, a couple seconds,
W: ...then take it out.
SFX: Portal shot
W: Like, eight feet. I'm gonna say this is - this is, like, ten feet away.
W: Here we are at twenty feet away.
W: Actually probably closer to, like, thirty feet.
W: If we're out in a public spot, I wouldn't really wanna go any further than this.
W: Huh.
W: Oh my god.
C:
W [discouraged]: Not good.
W: Hardcore bad... -ly stitched together.
W: Today is Monday. We're shooting the main video on Thursday,
Music: Vanishing Point, Corridor Digital
W: ...and this is not a promising test. I've got, basically, two days to figure this out.
W: We have to have a good solution by the end of Wednesday.
W: And right now...
W: ...it sucks.
SFX: Rising drumroll
Allen: Here, d'you wanna hold this? [laughing]
A: Luke Skywalker's lightsaber from A New Hope.
Brandon: So, Allen made this. This is a real-life lightsaber.
SFX: Lightsaber startup
A: Okay, so, you turn on the coil,
B: Yeah?
Sam: [indistinct]
A: So, I push down, nothing happens, that's fine.
SFX: Lihtsaber stratup
B: Yeah?
A: Turn the fuel off, grows hotter -
SFX: Lightsaber startup
SFX: Choir swelling
SFX: Choir swelling, slowed lightsaber startup
B:
A: [laughing]
D: So, what's your safe word?
S: [cry of fake-pain]
A, B, D, N: [laughing]
D: Towards the camera.
S: [cry of fake-pain]
A, D, N: [laughing]
B: [victory cry]
S: [cry of fake-pain]
A, D, N: [laughing, cheering]
B: Okay!
S: [cry of fake-pain]
S: [muffled cry of fake-pain]
A, B, D, N: [laughing]